OFFERING HIS SUPPORT SINCE NEWS
OF THE SHIRTING FOR
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            S
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            O
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            T
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            N
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            G
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            F
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            R
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            T
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            B
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            O
OF THE SHIRTING FOR            E
TODAY.
>> IN THE EAST ROOM, A SOMBER
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTING TO YET
ANOTHER SCHOOL SHOOTING.
>> President Trump:
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE TO BEGIN BY
EXPRESSING OUR SADNESS AND
HEARTBREAK OVER THE DEADLY
SHOOTING AT SANTA FE HIGH SCHOOL
IN TEXAS.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON TOO LONG
IN OUR COUNTRY.
TOO MANY YEARS, TOO MANY DECADES
NOW.
WE GRIEVE FOR THE TERRIBLE LOSS
OF LIFE AND TO SEND OUR SUPPORT
AND LOVE TO EVERYONE AFFECTED BY
THIS ABSOLUTELY HORRIFIC ATTACK.
>> Reporter: IN THE WAKE OF
THE LAST MAJOR SCHOOL SHOOTING,
MARJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH
AND FLORIDA, PRESIDENT TRUMP
HELD MEETINGS WITH VICTIMS
FAMILIES, GUN AND SCHOOL SAFETY
GROUPS.
HE PROPOSED SEVERAL SAFETY
REFORMS INCLUDING ARMY QUALIFIED
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF BUT
BACKED OFF THE CALL TO RAISE THE
MINIMUM AGE TO BUY A RIFLE FROM
18-21.
TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP FOUND
HIMSELF RIGHT BACK WHERE HE WAS
THE DAY OF THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING.
SPEAK TO MY ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO DETECT OUR STUDENTS,
SECURE OUR SCHOOLS AND KEEP
WEAPONS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
THOSE WHO POSE A THREAT.
EVERYONE MUST WORK TOGETHER AT
EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT TO
KEEP OUR CHILDREN SAFE.
>> Reporter: OF THE EVENT IN
THE EAST ROOM WAS TO HIGHLIGHT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SUPPORT FOR
PRISON REFORM.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO USED IT
TO MAKE A SURPRISE ANNOUNCEMENT,
INTRODUCING MEMBERS OF HIS
CABINET, THE PRESIDENT SHOCKED
HIS ACTING SECRETARY OF VETERANS
OF PICKED OUT AFFAIRS.
>> President Trump:
SECRETARY WILKIE WHO HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB AT THE VA, AND I WILL
BE INFORMING HIM IN A LITTLE
WHILE, HE DOESN'T KNOW THIS YET,
THAT WE WILL PUT HIS NAME UP FOR
NOMINATION TO BE SECRETARY OF
THE VETERANS ADMINISTRATION.
[APPLAUSE]
I'M SORRY THAT I RUINED THE
SURPRISE.
>> Reporter: WILKIE, WHO WAS
SERVING AS A UNDERSECRETARY OF
OF DEFENSE FOR PERSONNEL AND
READINESS BEFORE HE BECAME THE
ACTING SECRETARY HAS A DEEP
MILITARY BACKGROUND HAVING
SERVED IN BOTH THE NAVY AND
AIR FORCE, AND AT THE PENTAGON
DURING THE BUSH '43
ADMINISTRATION.
WE GOT A BETTER IDEA OF HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL PREPARE FOR
A SPECIAL INTERVIEW WITH SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER.
RUDY GIULIANI TELLING FOX NEWS
THAT THEY WILL MIRROR DEBATE
PREP DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
SOME SESSIONS MAY TAKE PLACE
AFTER HOURS AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
BUT GIULIANI PREFERS WEEKENDS AT
THE PRESIDENT SUMMER HOME IN
BEDMINSTER, NEW JERSEY.
GIULIANI IS ALSO CONSIDERING
BRINGING OUTSIDE PEOPLE INTO THE
PROCESS INCLUDING FORMER
NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR CHRIS
CHRISTIE WHO ALSO HELPED WITH
DEBATE PREP.
AND GIULIANI TELLS FOX NEWS THAT
ROBERT MUELLER HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
NARROWED THE SCOOPED ON
MICROSCOPE AND A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS HE WOULD ASK IN AN
INTERVIEW.
GIULIANI SAYS THE NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS IS DOWN FROM ABOUT 20,
250 AND THE TOPICS HAVE BEEN
NARROWED DOWN TO RUSSIA AND THE
FIRING OF JAMES COMEY.
GIULIANI TELLS FOX NEWS THAT HE
BELIEVES THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER HAS SHOWN
HE HAS ACTED IN GOOD FAITH BY
WHITTLING DOWN THE QUESTIONS.
AS TO WHEN THE PRESIDENT MIGHT
START PREPARING, GIULIANI SAYS
LIKELY NOT UNTIL AFTER THE
SUMMIT IN SOUTH KOREA BUT IF
THAT IS CANCELED, HE COULD BE
GETTING READY IN THE NEXT TWO OR
THREE WEEKS.
A DEVELOPMENT TODAY IN THE
MICHAEL COHEN CASE, AN ATTORNEY
FILED A MOTION IN NEW YORK CITY
TOOK IT TO STORMY DANIELS'
ATTORNEY OUT OF THE CASE IN THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
COHEN'S ATTORNEY SAYS HE
VIOLATED BY PUBLISHING BANK